hello
and happy unity everybody i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report
direct message for one 21
21 and it's an exciting time to be alive
we are united
we are healing everything is great
we have a new leader let's do it a lot
to talk about today i'm very excited for
the show actually because we're doing a
lot of video today
and there's all sorts of crazy things
happening in the world and i'm looking
forward to bringing you
all of those crazy things but before we
do anything else today uh
this is very important i have been
sitting here at my desk
this is the official reuben report desk
in the reuben report studio which is
also the reuben report office
and i've been sitting at my desk with a
pen
with blank printer paper people okay
heavy stock and i've been signing
executive actions
all morning it's not just joe biden and
donald
trump george w and barack obama that can
sign executive actions
i checked it out and according to a very
uh
little known legal loophole anyone can
sign executive actions
all you need is a piece of paper and a
pen preferably a sharpie
so all morning i've been signing
executive actions and just this morning
i signed this one
and i think this is pretty
groundbreaking this is the one you know
what i mean like i signed a whole bunch
of them
a lot of little things you know you
don't have to pick up
all dog poop depending on what time it
is things like that
but this is the one this is the one so
this is an official reuben report
executive action as you can see it says
ruben report executive action so
obviously it's official
leave me alone with exclamation point
and underlined so there's real emphasis
on it and i signed it myself
and it has today's date which of course
again is 1 21
21 so this is an official executive
action so that is leave me alone so that
means if anyone comes up to me on the
street and
yells at me about a mask or about the
dog poop or anything
i have signed a direct order and by the
way we're going to be enforcing it this
isn't going to be one of those flimsy
executive actions this is going to be
one of the serious ones so it's a very
exciting time around here
and i suspect over the course of the
next half hour
that i might sign some more i've got
blank paper
i've got a pen and as i'm talking to you
there might be some thoughts that pop up
in my head
and uh executive actions are the future
people that's how we're going to be
governed
edicts uh via paper and pen it's a very
exciting time
uh before we get to anything else guys
uh i just want to remind you that as of
yesterday i believe
uh we are now simulcasting the live
stream
on blaze tv so you can watch on youtube
or you can watch on blaze tv
and right now if you sign up for blaze
tv
you can get 30 off your subscription not
too bad
and before we get to all the stories of
the day oh i'm definitely going to sign
more
executive actions i can feel it here
i've already uncapped the pen so the pen
is in hand
ready to roll something's going to
happen uh i want to talk to you guys
about expressvpn you all know how
concerned i am about censorship on
social media sites and what we can do
about it i think i've been talking about
that a little bit the left wants to
silence and remove any videos and voices
they don't agree with twitter and
facebook are supposed to be open
platforms i don't need their content
moderators acting like the op-ed section
of the new york times
so instead of letting social media sites
revoke our right to free speech how
about revoking their right to our data
now we could just deactivate all our
social media accounts and it's tempting
but that would be giving the left just
what they want in the first place
instead i suggest using expressvpn ever
wonder
how free to access sites like facebook
make all their money while they're
tracking your searches video history
and everything you click on and then
selling your valuable data
when you use expressvpn you anonymize
much of your online presence by hiding
your ip address that makes your activity
more difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers and expressvpn couldn't be
easier to set up
you just tap one button on your phone or
computer and you're protected expressv
vpn also encrypts a hundred percent of
your data to protect you from hackers
and assorted internet bad guys it's
finally time to say no to censorship and
take back your online privacy at
expressvpn.com
reuben by visiting my special link
you'll get an extra three months of
expressvpn
service for free again that's express e
x p r e
s s v p n dot com slash reuben
expressvpn.com
ruben to protect your data today
all right here we go people should i
sign an executive action right now you
know before we get going
ruben report
executive
action what should this one be
i think here for a moment um
i got it no well i'm gonna write it out
first
sign it date it so it's official
all right i've signed another reuben
report
executive action i think this is a big
one people
yeah i feel good about this one reuben
report executive action
no more watching cnn okay no more
i've signed it dated it it's on the
paper
okay we might shellack it do we have a
shellacker here like a laminator machine
or something we're gonna get a
laminating machine
we're gonna laminate it all right there
you go
all right let's get to some stories so
you're not gonna believe this but the
media
is still obsessed with that t guy that
trump guy they
just can't get over it uh and former cia
director wait for john brennan cia or
fbi i think he's fbi
we'll i'll clarify that in just a second
uh but john brennan
who really has turned into basically
just
a partisan hack constantly screaming
about how evil the right is
a cia i was right the first time he was
the former head of the cia
under obama uh he was on msnbc
talking about the trump insurgency and i
think there's a couple buzz words in
here that we're gonna have to unpack
let's take a look
because of this growth in polarization
in the united states
and domestic violence in white
supremacist groups
so i know looking forward that the
members of the the biden team
who have been nominated or have been
appointed
are now moving in laser-like fashion to
try to uncover as much they can
about what looks very similar to
insurgency movements that we've seen
overseas
where they germinate in different parts
of the country and they gain strength
and it brings together an unholy
alliance frequently
of religious religious extremists
authoritarians fascists
bigots racists nativists
even libertarians and unfortunately i
think there has been this momentum that
has been generated as a result of
unfortunately the demagogue rhetoric of
people that's just
departed government but also those who
continue in the halls of congress
and so i really do uh think that the law
enforcement homeland security
intelligence and even the defense
officials
are doing everything possible to root
out what seems to be a very very serious
and insidious threat
to our democracy in our oh there is a
serious and insidious threat to our
democracy here but i'm pretty sure it's
you
john brennan um let's just review some
of the people he included in his list of
people that should be checked out
because they're doing bad things which
in essence
is just people who disagree with him
politically you've got your
religious extremists now of course we
don't want religious extremists blowing
things up
whether they were christian uh religious
extremists or jewish
religious extremists or muslim religious
extremist but i don't think that's
exactly what he's talking about he's
kind of just saying christian people
like that's the code word you can sort
of
read into what he's saying like people
who have a belief system
because the hyper secular progressive
movement doesn't want
people with any religious belief or any
belief in anything uh
bigots bigots are part of this well
first off i mean
they believe and they've been saying for
years that half of the country is bigots
right half of the country's deplorables
half of the country's
white supremacists and everything by the
way you're allowed to be a bigot i
would prefer we didn't have bigots like
i would prefer that most people just
judge people by the content of their
character not the color of their skin
but you're allowed to be a bigot in a
free society like you really are you
know archie bunker
remember all in the family he was a
bigot right and did you want archie
bunker pulled out of society and shot
well i suppose maybe
maybe they did that would have been a
spin-off show the progressives are in
power watch us
assassinate uh archie bunker who by the
way his best friend was george jefferson
it's a whole whole other thing it was a
different time
point is uh he also throws in so you got
your religious extremists you got your
bigots
your authoritarians i mean that that's
just sort of like what do you mean
you're authoritarians like you guys are
the authoritarians you love state power
so are you going to be arresting
yourselves i'm not really sure what
you're talking about and then of course
the one that we have to get to oh and
then he says racists i mean what i just
said about bigots goes for that
i mean just that you're all we're all
racist right if we don't agree
with critical race theory if we don't
agree with identity politics if we
actually believe
that things should be governed the way
they always have been governed and the
united states is fundamentally good in
the constitution has freed us and all of
those things
we're racist and we're bigots we know
that much uh
and finally the last one was
libertarians he throws libertarians in
there
that was sort of like a little bonus one
for us so you've got your authoritarians
and your libertarians
those are totally reverse but we can put
them all together
because they're a you know a collection
of bad people libertarians let's just
real quick
uh i think most of you know this already
libertarians basically believe in
individual liberty
that's it and they want very little and
often no
government coercion and then we can
whittle down whether we should have
police departments and fire departments
or should we even privatize those things
but the idea that that libertarians
um are extremists that would somehow
want violent extremism is completely
bananas although that's completely
consistent
with the way mainstream media always
talks about libertarians let's not
forget ron paul who i had on a few days
ago who is
former congressman from texas who's been
the leader really of the liberty
movement in america for the last couple
decades
when he started the tea party back in
2008 when he was running for president
and there were thousands and thousands
of people at his rallies it was sort of
a precursor to a trump thing in a
certain way in in
in the sort of constitutional
pro-america sense of it
um what did the what did mainstream
media do they said they were a bunch of
backwards redneck racist
blah blah blah blah blah so the idea
though that you would put libertarians
who want no government coercion with
authoritarians who want all government
coercion and then you just toss in the
biggest and the racist it's just
it's just a load of nonsense uh
let's move on though because they're
they're just not stopping with this idea
that 74 million plus people are
bigots and racists and evil and they
want to reprogram you and deprogram you
here's katie couric who is a former
journalist i don't know what she
considers herself now
she was on bill maher and she had this
to say
but i also think some of them are
believing the garbage that they are
being fed
24 7. on the internet by their
constituents and they
bought into this big lie and the
question is how are we going to
really almost de-program these people
who have signed up
for the cult of trump guys don't forget
she and people like her are good guys
and you and people like you are bad guys
how are
they going to deprogram you she has
bought in
to progressivism right into rampant
secularism she has
bought in to all of these ideas that
feel empowered right now they feel that
they're winning
and the other half of the country that
we've always made fun of and put down
and called all
the awful things who get their news
elsewhere and who have started to
wake up and who have started to be red
pilled and whatever else the more you
guys know about stuff the more we're
gonna have to say that you have to be
deprogrammed because we're free thinkers
and you guys are really really bad
people katie
you see what's going on here by the way
katie if you're watching this or if
anyone that knows katie couric is
watching i'd be happy to sit down with
you
no notes fully live no edits blah blah
blah we can talk about
all of this stuff that of course was on
bill maher's show
and i would love to talk to bill maher
you know they had booked me when my book
came out then kobit happened then they
sort of rebooked me again
i kind of knew it wasn't going to happen
the whole time because i think at this
point
although i admired bill for years i
think i think the trump stuff kind of
went overboard and i know a lot of the
bill maher producers and people watch
the show hi guys how are you
um and i think i've sort of made a move
in terms of what a true liberal is that
bill refuses to make because of the the
trump derangement stuff and
and that he still thinks he's a
progressive and he'll have you know
he'll have
adam schiff on to talk about why people
are leaving california and then he
doesn't realize that he's
you know promoting all of the
progressive politics that caused people
to leave high taxes high
crime high drug use unemployment
homelessness etc
etc um but all right sometimes the media
does move on and in some ways they have
uh they have started doing some stories
about
joe biden here's one of the questions
that jen pasaki his new
uh she's the press secretary the new
press secretary got
yesterday it's very it's very in-depth
and biting
a lighter note will he keep donald
trump's air force one color scheme
change
this is such a good question i have not
had the opportunity to dig into that
today
given the number of executive actions
orders the inauguration
a few things happening i will venture to
get you an answer on that and maybe we
can talk about it in here tomorrow
this is such a good question that's such
a good question about the color of the
thing
and the plane and what are we going to
do and let's see about the carpet and
all of those things it's such a good
question and why did they have to ask me
questions
about the other things because that's
such a good question do you see how
stupid this is gonna be
we are just going to be in the worst
reality show
of all time like trump was a reality
show and like him or hate him or
whatever it was like there was some good
stuff there there was some funny stuff
there was some irreverent stuff
something
remotely close to reality but now you're
going to have just this press corps that
half
that you know they want these people in
power so they're going to ask
ask half-assed questions that'll be
thought of as controversial
and then mostly they're gonna ask about
uh whether they're gonna change the
drapes
in the uh airplane bathroom oh my god
that's such a good question
it's such a good question can you ask it
again in another way
um but not just that i i found this one
which was really interesting biden was
talking yesterday
about uh how he would fire disrespectful
colleagues he's not going to tolerate
being disrespectful to people i mean
that's not something a good
progressive liberal lefty would do let's
listen in
but i'm not joking when i say this if
you're ever working with me
and i hear you treat another colleague
with disrespect
talk down to someone i promise you i
will fire you on the spot
on the spot no if ands or buts
everybody everybody is entitled to be
treated with decency
and dignity that's been missing in a big
way
the last four years it's true it's true
treating people with dignity and respect
and not talking down to people is
important
uh but we just happened to come across
this video
during the campaign of joe biden talking
to
auto worker jerry wayne who by the way i
had on the show
after this interaction and let's just
see how respectful
and tolerant and decent and all that
good stuff joe
was to gerry
second amendment just like
i'm not taking your gun away at all you
need a hundred rounds
i did not say that that's not i did not
say
the video it's a viral video like the
other ones are putting out that they're
simply alive
just to reiterate what happened there
not only did he tell jerry wayne who was
an
auto worker and a private citizen that
he's full of [ __ ] he told him to shush
then he said you want to take him out
back or something you want to go outside
so he threatened to
fight him uh in joe biden's defense in
the original video that we showed of
yesterday
he said that you have to treat
colleagues with respect and it's very
obvious that joe biden thinks he's the
better of jerry wayne they're not
colleagues he's a politician
jerry wayne is but a uh a humble citizen
of the united states so so joe is better
anyway i'm only showing you this just to
show you that all of the things
healing unity all the things they all
just sound nice but if you think that
these people actually mean it
then i would like to sell you a bridge
to nowhere that would be nice oh and
speaking of bridges to nowhere so one of
the things that
joe biden did signing executive actions
yesterday and again they all do it
everybody signs executive actions
uh oh and by the way you know i when i
talked about executive actions yesterday
we've read off a whole bunch of them a
few of you pointed out to me
that when we read the numbers trump did
have the fewest numbers of executive
actions
the last couple presidents but he also
was the only one-term president of it so
fully i'm fully happy to acknowledge
that i don't like executive actions
whether they're done by republicans or
done by democrats i mean that's just not
the way we should be ruled
and you can feel it right you can feel
it right now we do things one way
four years later we do them the other
let's have mass bipolar disorder
but in any event joe biden did sign some
executive actions yesterday including an
executive action
that would make peop everyone would have
to
wear a mask on federal property he
signed that
and then he went to the lincoln memorial
[Music]
impeach it's the only way i demand it i
henceforth
demand impeachment i might write an
executive action on that right now that
we must
impeach people who sign executive
actions and then within a half hour
walk to federal property after the
executive action that they just signed
said
you can't be on federal poverty without
a mask and then they don't have a mask i
might have to sign an executive action
on that because the hypocrisy
is off the charts i believe they call
this do as i say not as i do
and by the way yes it's a little silly
he's sort of standing there alone okay i
don't really care
but there's also a picture that you can
find of like seven
of his granddaughters all standing
together no social distancing
not wearing masks and of course there on
federal property as well so
it's just a series of unfortunate idiocy
uh but i want to show you one other
thing not that directly related to
inauguration well actually i guess it's
kind of related to another well it's
very
related to inauguration i've completely
changed my mind in under three seconds
uh antifa you know these people the
anti-fascists who are actually the
fascists the people who are bringing
violence
to all of our cities the people who've
been encouraged by maxine waters and
nancy pelosi and chris cuomo and don
lemon
and the people who often get good
coverage and ali velshi stands there
with buildings blowing up behind him
telling you
it's mostly peaceful protests and
they're here to destroy the system
that's what they're telling you and they
want revenge on america and
all of that stuff right um and they're
breaking windows and half of
the area that i live in is still boarded
up because of antifa
violence um but you know they're also
the good guys
uh well they were in portland last night
and uh well we threw together a little
compilation of what's going on in
portland and i promise you
you're not going to see this on cnn
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
oh
somebody please please get that video to
jake tapper he obviously
hasn't been able to see it someone get
it to stelter
to acosta to blitzer these people yeah
cnn's just not going to cover it please
prove me wrong cnn
prove me wrong now again this is the
type of violence that these people like
now what's odd here is you know i
thought that violence was only by
the white supremacists and the
libertarians the authoritarians those
mean people
these people coordinate by the way on
all of big social media they coordinate
on reddit they coordinate on twitter
suddenly
i don't know i don't see anyone getting
deleted or banned or servers exploding
or anything else hypocrisy you know no
bounds
but while we were watching that video it
hit me wait a minute
these portland people they're just
destroying the city you could see them
attacking by the way one of the
buildings they were attacking was the
democratic
party headquarters where they were
smashing windows or showing that it
looked like they were attacking
a train station a bunch of other stuff
and then it hit me it was like wait a
minute why don't i do something about
this
obviously cnn's not going to do anything
about it obviously
ted wheeler that dingbat [ __ ] mayor of
portland's not going to do anything
about it so i said
dave you have a pen you have paper sign
an executive action
i have signed an executive action ladies
and gentlemen ruben report executive
action this is executive action number
three we're gonna have to start
numbering these
antifa equals bad antifa
bad okay dave rubin 121 21.
so you know a lot of people just talk
right everyone just talks
dave rubin does that's the difference
between me and my critics okay uh
ladles and jelly spoons i've enjoyed
talking to you today uh we've got more
coming i think i'm gonna sign some more
executive actions tomorrow
a lot of interesting things happening
over on locals by the way
and and with the company and all sorts
of stuff so i got a whole bunch of
meetings today
but see what's going on at
locals.reubenreport.com oh and by the
way
uh tomorrow we're doing our second ever
panel uh we
we did one two weeks ago then we didn't
do it last friday because i wanted to
give my guys a four day weekend
uh because we had uh mlk day obviously
on monday and i felt like we were
we were busting our butts enough i
wanted people to relax so tomorrow
uh we will be doing a four person panel
with yours truly
uh sean spicer seb gorka and
jack murphy i'm psyched to talk about
all these guys who are sort of in the
trump world and sort of what happens now
to either the trump movement or america
first
or the republican party and we'll talk
about maybe we'll talk about the
progressives who the hell knows you
never know what's going to happen here
on the reuben report
that of course will be at 11 a.m pacific
2 p.m eastern time oh and by the way
uh we just posted part one of my
interview
with jason reilly from the manhattan
institute and
he's a super interesting guy who just
released a documentary it's coming out
this weekend
actually uh about thomas soule i'm i'm
in it quite heavily but it's a good
documentary even despite that
and he has a book coming out about
thomas soul and we talk about race
relations and economics and obviously a
lot about the documentary and for those
of you who love
thomas all as much as i do i think
you'll really enjoy it so check
that out it was posted this morning and
uh you know
have a nice day all right see ya
you